so hello everybody i am with richard
rowland who at this point doesn't need
any introduction and we're really
excited to go into our second part
of the the grail symbolism we did the
last video with a really great reaction
and so uh richard take it away let's
start us off
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
so
yeah a lot of people really liked the
last video we also got a little bit of
just a small amount of controversy that
was sparked by the last video as well
which is always exciting to see
um and i want to reiterate that one of
the reasons actually i recorded an a
podcast episode about this uh with
somebody recently and then we got to the
end we realized that neither of us had
hit the record button oh no so now
there's just a lost conversation out
there and it was when i was over the guy
that i was recording with he's a priest
he was really
uh really upbeat about it and really you
know it's just like listen if this
conversation isn't good enough
for us to enjoy then there's no point in
doing it so don't feel bad about it now
we have a cool lost episode but anyway
um more about that maybe in the future
but uh one of the things we were talking
about is is one of the reasons that i'm
so interested in the arthurian stories
in the grail particularly but in really
all the arthurian stuff i mean i've got
entire bookshelf over here just mostly
arthurian stuff uh two or three shelves
um
is because i think that the arthurian
uh
i don't know you want to call it a
mythos or a cycle or because you know
it's like it's like it's like a group of
legends there's no canonical
you know definitive this is the
authoritative arthur
but it it kind of contains within itself
everything that's
good and noble
but also everything that's a problem
about being a western person right and i
really want to say that both the good
and the bad are in there um i hope that
you know as we're doing these great
videos
um i'm i'm i mean i'm a western person
you know i'm not anti-western i'm just
trying to sort of deal with where i am
in in the world and in history and i i
found the grey of legends to be really
helpful to do what was the controversy i
don't even know i there were some people
some people were like oh well you're
just you're just saying you know all
these you know things the west is
terrible blah blah blah you know because
we got into the end you know there's
there's there's this whole school of
thought this whole school of thought of
uh
um which i tend to agree with that that
traces the origins of the grail legend
to
um the fourth crusade and the holy
mackerel and the shroud of turin and all
this stuff right
um so obviously that stuff is uh
it's a little still a little
historically painful if it wasn't
historically painful uh the pope
wouldn't have apologized for it you know
this last week i think
he's making a tour
of like crete and other places
um so it's still very historically
painful for a lot of people and uh my
point in bringing that stuff up is not
to like make a thing out of it it's just
to say historically if that stuff didn't
happen we wouldn't get the grail story
right like the one thing all the stuff
flows out of this
sense of ruptured communion and of
course also these debates about
communion itself which kind of manifest
in the west right around the time that
the grail legends kind of become a thing
okay
yeah yeah so i just you know just want
to kind of put that out there um
um when i'm talking about the stuff it's
it's because i really do deeply love it
um especially especially the story we're
going to talk about today which is a
christian's um
story of the grail um
and there's got a french title which i'm
not going to try to embarrass myself
to a native french speaker uh by saying
but um but anyway so it's it's the story
of the grail
and um
it is the first grail romance
so before this
there are no holy grail stories as such
and i would just want to point out that
this grail story is not
exactly the version that people remember
because the version that people remember
has like these indiana jones and monty
python layers on it but ultimately it
goes back to for english speaking people
usually goes back the to sir thomas
mallory's lemore d'arthur which has
basically the
the the the final form of the french
version of the story which
is like the like the french the lancelot
grail vulgate cycle that that that's
what mallory is working from so that's
what most of us actually know this comes
a long time before that
it's the first ever grail romance and i
think it's also in many ways the most
symbolically insightful
but i just want to point out that
this story is a really beautiful story
it's weird it's rich it's wonderful
so don't just like sit down and read
this to like strip mine it for symbolic
content or something like that um
because there's always a danger for
people like us to do that but this is i
mean the story just the beginning of the
story just the first three or four pages
i'm going to be reading today out of
this edition by the way this is the
complete romances of kreti and
it's translated by david stains i think
is how you say his name you can find
this on amazon
it's a pretty good translation one of
the things i like about it is the fact
that it's a prose translation
which i'm not generally a big fan of
doing although i have done some of these
myself i'm not generally a big fan of
doing verse to verse translations from
other languages um because it's just
very difficult to pull off the effect of
the normal verse and so in that case i
what i would rather have is like a
really good prose translation that would
then support my
attempts to go back and and kind of
wrestle with the poetry in the original
language so anyway this is a good this
is a good translation
and um
i just want to say that
the
uh my interest in the grail legends and
the grail stories actually begins with
uh sort of an encounter in the liturgy
that i had um and it was this beautiful
uh 6 a.m divine liturgy um
there's a greek church near my house and
one one year during the nativity fest in
fact
we're just a couple of days as we're
recording this the day after like the
two or three year anniversary of when
this happened okay
um the day after the uh uh it was it was
a 6am liturgy for saint nicholas so that
was yesterday
you know for us
and um
we i was i was in the church and it was
this you know it's this beautiful sort
of basilica basilica-style church it's
one of the best churches in in the north
texas area it's totally dark
um just lit by candles
and there was like one chanter it's just
really really good
uh byzantine chanter
and um it was just him and maybe one or
two other people with him and they were
doing the whole service and it was
during the terubikim
and uh
you see the
you see the um you know they're coming
up the center of the church with the
with the gifts
and as they're doing this you know i see
here's the altar server
bearing the taper
and the deacon with a patent
and the
priest with the chalice and everything
is dark and there's light and there's
lights and incidents and everything and
i just sort of had this flashback to
reading this romance and just this
realization it's like this is i'm in the
grail chapel right now like what what is
happening and some other things that
some other pretty incredible things
happened later that morning but
uh for me that was the moment that kind
of tied it all together a moment of
intuition during the liturgy and then
that's kind of that's kind of what all
of this came out of
so um
there was a english occultist named a.e
waite who wrote a uh
wrote a book called i think it's called
the high history of the holy grail and
it's pretty interesting um
actually i think it's called the holy
grail history legend and symbolism but
maybe maybe you also wrote a book called
the high history of the holy grail
anyway
um
uh wait is an occultist he's a you know
theosophist i don't really recommend
anybody go and read his stuff i think
he's
sketchy as heck but um
uh but he was part of this group of
people in england um and most of them
were like sort of you could say
disaffected anglicans yeah sort of felt
like the
uh the mystical aspects of christianity
were missing from their church and this
is all tied up with the whole movement
of celtic romanticism yeah right which
is to say you know
it's this is it's tied up with
nationalism chelsea romanticism
basically celtic romanticism is the idea
that celtic people as a race
okay and i put that in scare quotes as a
race are uh they're like more naturally
intuitive and spiritual and wild and
free and yeah all this stuff it's like
you know like enya's first album
basically
and and um
oh it's hilarious man yeah um
um i actually it was also like it was a
nationalist moment in revenge of the
whole like of the the anglo-saxon yeah
it was like it was like a thousand years
too late but it was like this sort of
like revenge for the the anglo-saxon
invasion where he had all of these
anglo-saxons you know suddenly saying
well we got to get back to our celtic
roots right yeah um and so that's that's
what a lot of this was tied up with and
so one of the things that people started
trying to search for and there's still
people who are hung up on this today is
this idea of like reconstructing or
finding like this this lost celtic
liturgy yeah this idea that there would
be a celtic
expression
of christianity that would be authentic
to the british isles in a way that latin
right roman catholicism and then also
anglican aglicanism as something that
developed out of that yeah um that
it would be authentic in a way that
those weren't yeah um and so
these guys looked back to the grails
story and they looked at it and they
said oh look it's so liturgical it's
there's chalices and you know it's the
body and blood of christ all this stuff
it's which is so liturgical this must
this legend must actually be about the
true celtic lost celtic liturgy and all
of these stupid continental romances
turn it into this adventure story and
they got it totally wrong so a lot of
you guys hated the romances because
and what i would like to say is these
guys are
but that's interesting that it's
interesting that they would see they
would see
the grail legend as a nostalgia for the
lost
celtic christianity in general like that
that when the the anglo-saxons brought
in the latin mass and kind of imposed
rome
uh on the the let's say on the british
isles then that would have been
like they would have lost something and
that would be a memory of that in the in
the king arthur because king arthur is
from before that time like obviously
right and yeah that's that whole thing
is a is a complicated question and i'm
actually working on putting a new
podcast together for ancient faith which
will hopefully be all about the history
of the english conversion um but i
haven't had another podcast are you
sorry i haven't had time to work on it
this fall but i'm hoping that maybe
january february that'll drop so keep an
eye out for that um and if you if you
like because because that whole question
of conversion uh the conversion of the
anglo-saxon peoples is really
interesting to me but basically i think
these guys are
in they have the right intuition
but they totally misread the mystery the
romances because in some senses they're
blinded a little bit
by this sort of you know this celtic
romanticism right
so what i want to basically uh
try to demonstrate in by by doing a
close reading of christian's romance
is two things one is that this structure
of the story itself or at least those
parts the story is really has two parts
that are uh
they're connected by a medieval
technique called interlace which is
basically where you have threads of two
stories that move in and out of each
other at multiple points this is very
common in arthurian stories which is why
if you've ever sat down and you've just
tried to read an arthurian story and
you're like oh it's christmas and we're
at the court and then a little white dog
runs in and he's followed by like three
stags and a princess who's weeping and
then some guy goes to deal with that
problem and on the way he gets
challenged and then we learn about this
night that and it's like it's like why
can't we just stick with one plot thread
right but it's it's because these these
plot threads are are interlaced so they
kind of weave in and out of each other
and you just have to sort of like
set aside your modern three-act
narrative expectations and kind of just
hang on so this story has basically two
threads like that one is about percival
and the other is about uh gawain
um but at least the percival part of the
story
is fundamentally structured according to
the pattern of the divine liturgy and i
think this is absolutely indisputable
the second thing that i want to try to
prove is that everyone has been reading
this story in completely the wrong way
or at least everyone has been everyone
everyone i'm the first one to get it
right jonathan you guys heard it here
now let me let me let me
i'll nuance that a little bit i like to
say that provocatively because it gets
people's attention but um
everyone believes that the story is
unfinished and that percival never finds
the grail and everyone in the middle
ages believe that which is why i have a
book right here
if i can if i can if i can pick it up
without knocking down all of the other
books stacked on top of it i have a book
right here that has all of the medieval
continuations of the personal romance
so everybody was unsatisfied with the
way that the story doesn't end
and uh and they try to write their own
continuations of it right but what i
want to argue is that if you read the
text closely you'll see that percival
actually does succeed he actually does
achieve the grail
so so let's talk a little bit about the
story
so
percival
we don't actually learn his name until
about halfway through the poem
um in fact he doesn't learn his name
until about halfway through the poem
first of all begins totally without
identity he only knows himself in
relation to his mother and so when he's
first asked what's your name somebody
asked him what's your name he says well
my name is dear son because that's what
his mother calls him and or in relation
to his to the to his servants who call
him dear masters he was like it's like
well what's your other name well my
other name is dear master right
uh he doesn't know himself though in
relation to his father so this is a very
important detail in personal story his
father is a knight who died in battle
due to a grave injury to the loins
okay
um
and the reason that his mother will not
tell him who he is won't tell him his
name or who his father was is because
she doesn't want him to become a knight
she doesn't want him to grow up and die
the same way that her fa
that his father did so
so the other hint that we get about
percival's
uh identity is his clothing so clothing
that putting on and taking off of
garments and often we're told that
they're garments of coarse hair
regardless of skins in this story like
very literally explicitly
um that's very important to pay
attention to as you read this this
romance not just with percival i'm going
to give some examples of that but also
with the other the like the side
characters as well
um we're told when he's his clothing is
first described we are told that he
dresses like a welshman which is not a
compliment as far as christian is
concerned um the idea is he's sort of
like dressed in like butt uh you know
like buskins like you know um you know
he looks looks like a rustic right yeah
he's rustic
um and by his activities so his his his
hobby
um the thing that he likes to do is he
has this javelin and then he and it
talks and spends a whole lot of time
about talking about him like he's
walking along he's throwing the javelin
north south east and west towards every
point of the compass and the idea i
think here is that his identity is
scattered and it's focused
right now i i said and i gave reasons
for this in our previous video but i
said that essentially
this
uh this this poem follows the structure
of the divine liturgy
and you could say wouldn't that also
make sense if you're saying that his
identity is scattered or that it's yeah
that that's
would also the idea of his father dying
from an injury in the loins would
definitely go with that yes right yeah
those two things are really really
closely connected yeah so and i think
that the you could say the liturgical
structure of this poem you could chalk
it up to two things one is there does
seem to be lots and lots and lots of
evidence
that the grail legends uh developed at
least partially out of byzantine
liturgic liturgical commentaries like
that of saint germain so i mean that's
so there's an explicit connection there
but also
i believe and i think that you believe
that the liturgy is the shape of
everything right so whether or not you
can demonstrate that christiane ever
spoke to somebody who's seen a byzantine
divine liturgy although he almost
certainly had because obvious patrons
were these crusader families
um but whether or not he'd actually seen
like an eastern right divine liturgy or
or read that kind of kind of a
commentary i think because
this the structure of the story is so
fundamentally symbolic and cosmic that
it's it's uh it's unavoidable
so if we wanted to sort of look at this
through the lens of liturgy we can see
this um
different liturgical commentators talk
about the way that we are before we come
together for the synopsis before we come
together for the gathering right which
is not just a gathering of us as as a
people as a like a congregation but it's
also a gathering of our scattered
identity we've been out in the world
we've been pulled this way by this thing
and that way by that thing and we're
just all
we're all scattered and dissolute and
all of these things being pulled
together
when we decide we're going to enter into
the church
and so what we see is that at each part
of the story percival has these changes
that come up uh come with a movement up
the you could say like a movement up the
ontological hierarchy right so
everything's a mountain right or a tree
right so as he moves up to each level
he has to change clothing he has to be
given a set of instructions for how to
behave himself on the next level and
then what we see happening in the story
is him
doing or not doing that well depending
on the case so in this case he begins
with a totally scattered loss of
identity
and then he's off in the forest he's
playing with his javelin he's doing all
this stuff and suddenly he hears some
knights riding through the bushes like
in the forest right and he's in the
forest sauvage so the the savage forest
the wasteland the wild forest the wild
forest
and um
as he hears the knights coming he
actually thinks that they're demons
because of the sound they're making it's
it's a big scary sound he's never heard
anything like this and this is actually
where we find out how much chretien or
how much percival knows about god which
is really important
because he doesn't know much he's been
taught the creed he's been taught the
our father and he's been taught that
he's supposed to make the sign of the
cross when he hears something coming
or when something scares him to frighten
the demons away but he says i'm not
going to make the sign of the cross
instead i'm going to wait here
and when the demons appear i'm going to
strike them with my javelin and kill
them
so that's his his attitude and when he
sees the knights come through he sees
them
and he immediately changes his mind he
says i have sinned grievously
uh to call them devils because my mother
told me no idol tell when she said to me
that angels were the most beautiful
creatures there are except god who is
the most beautiful of all
here i behold the lord god i believe for
one of them is so beautiful
that the others so help me god have not
attempted this beauty so he thinks he
sees the most beautiful night and the
other night's with me thinks i must be
seeing god and his angels
so
he's very confused he doesn't know what
he's dealing with and basically the
knights set him straight and they
explain well we're not gods we're not
angels we're knights and first of all is
like what is a night i've never heard of
this before so they start having this
conversation and this is when things get
really interesting
because he walks up to the night on the
horse and he looks at the knights lance
and he says
what is that you're holding
and what's it for
now it starts with a lance this is
really important
because that is the first thing in the
grail procession that we're going to
talk about in a minute yeah yeah and so
the knight explains to him what the
lance is and what it's for
and then he said looks the shield which
is shaped like a dish and he says what
is that and what is it for
and he starts going through all of their
stuff until he gets to their armor their
haubergs and when he gets their hobbics
the question he asks is not what is that
and what is this for but he says
how does that serve
right that's his question about the
knights gear
is how does it serve
um and
this is so this is the question that
he's asking when he's faced with you
could say the next
thing on the ladder of ontological
hierarchy
uh so he goes back to his mother and he
questions her he learns the first time
about his father he look who is this
crippled knight who was pierced through
the thighs who could not defend his
lands or his fortune so when king arthur
pendragon
uh they lost everything uh he had to be
carried on a litter because he couldn't
ride his horse all this stuff
she sees that she cannot dissuade him
from his intent to leave home now and
become a knight and so percival's mother
gives him
a
series of instructions and she limits
the fact that he'll probably be killed
because he doesn't know how to fight but
she gives him a series of instructions
and the instructions that he gets at
each level of the ontological hierarchy
are very important the first instruction
he get he's given is to give aid to any
lady he meets okay this is important
part of chivalry and this comes with a
provisio that he's allowed to accept any
token that he's given from a lady up to
a kiss
but if the lady tries to give you
anything more than a kiss percival
you gotta say no yeah it's very
delicately put in the bone
second thing he's supposed to do is to
ask the name of any man who shows him
hospitality because she says and i quote
this is from the poem it is by the name
that we know the man.
now percival still hasn't been told his
name we don't even know his name he's
just called a young man at this point in
the poem yeah so we don't know him and
he doesn't know himself
the third thing he's told is that he's
to stop and pray at a church or at any
church or chapel that he comes across
and percival doesn't know what a church
or chapel is because he's never seen one
before
and so he's told that this is a place
quote filled with relics treasures holy
wherein they offer up the body of jesus
christ so already there's this
foreshadowing of what the grail is
all right
so uh keeping all of these things in
mind percival doesn't yet have an
identity he doesn't have a name he
doesn't know how to act in the new world
that he's entered into and this
introduces a theme that we see repeat
itself over and over again in the poem
which is that as percival climbs the
ontological hierarchy he always lacks
the information we can say he lacks the
manners that he needs to move in that
particular rung of the ladder so can you
just say something that's interesting
i just want to mention something that
the structure that you're you're
presenting it's very it's it's very
powerful
because even the idea that he's in the
wild is part of it like he's definitely
all everything there is there to show
that he doesn't have an identity and so
we there are several stories where
angels like even in the gospel when the
apostles come to encounter the pagans
and then they're like oh they they
they bow down before them it's because
you can understand that whatever level
you are if you receive something from
above it can appear to you at first as
being the highest thing right that's the
problem of idolatry itself is that
something comes from above and so you're
like okay this that's the thing that
appears to me it's the highest thing and
so luckily for him the the knights were
those that would render glory up right
and say no it doesn't it's not us like
maybe we like in a way they were
vehicles for him to go up the the ladder
but they're able to to place themselves
properly in a way as true angels and say
no it's like we're just messengers for
something higher that you need to access
later let's say and that can help you
understand why the flattened cosmology
that most of us are working with most of
the time today
why a it's very difficult for somebody
in that mindset to understand
traditional christian veneration
right because you you you see something
like an icon of the mother of god and
and you see us kissing it or or hear the
things that we're saying about her and
you're like oh you must think she's the
highest thing but we don't think she's
the highest name there's
it's there's something infinitely above
her right uh but um
uh but but because when you have this
flattened cosmology you're always liable
to look at any bright thing that
presents itself to your attention as
this is the highest thing now which is
why it's also simul while simultaneously
it makes you
you know maybe a little paranoid about
idolatry in that form yeah okay it also
makes you very liable to
idolatry when like a a really great
athlete
uh or a a pastor you really love who's a
really good preacher or something like
that when that person presents themself
right um because because there's just
there's not room
in your field of attention for
a normal high escalating levels a normal
hierarchy yeah so um
so so
he has to rely on the advice that he
gets from the guardian of each threshold
uh which is advice which he only ever
sort of imperfectly puts into place
and you could say this sort of for us
corresponds to the entrance into the
church
both our entrance you know for the first
time when catechesis begins we take our
first step up the mountain
right and so we're told that percival is
clothed by his mother in these garments
of skin they're specifically said to be
garments of skin uh he's dressed like a
welshman
um and he and and he crosses a river to
leave his home nice and by the way every
time
that he comes to a new you could say
like a new tier
a new rung in the ontological hierarchy
he crosses a river so that's a just a
very easy sort of symbolic key that you
can look for in the story okay it's a
very again it's a very beautifully
structured story
um and so
uh garments are very important in the
story and they signal the way that old
and new things identities are adopted or
cast off
their coverings they're things that are
used to both can protect from danger but
also to confer identity
so in mystical terms we could say we're
in the narthex now
so percival's first few encounters in
the world of chivalry do not go smoothly
i'm not going to like summarize the
entire poem because it's pretty long but
essentially he meets a maiden and
instead of simply receiving her ring as
a free gift he misunderstands his
mother's instructions and he takes the
ring also a kiss
which actually causes a rift between her
and her very jealous lover who he who
believes that she has now been
unfaithful to him and it's a whole thing
uh she'll she comes up later she
actually turns out to be principal's
cousin which is super awkward um
percival also meets a particularly
troublesome night known as the red
knight the red knight has stolen
guess what he's stolen
john i don't remember what he said
stolen a cup
okay from arthur's court
um guinevere's favorite cup and as a
result
the king the the court of arthur has
been thrown into
silence
okay
everyone is sad there's no more laughter
but it's science and again
silence and laughter
and speaking too much or being silent
too much those are like to the main
uh contrast in this poem okay
so he's stolen arthur's cup
um and uh so you know watch for some of
these themes as they come up up come up
again there's a heavy silence laying on
everyone except for sir k who is the
king's seneschal his sort of foster
brother and who in this particular poem
is
a pretty awful person and so he uh he
laughs and disparages uh uh percival
because of
principle's bad manners which include
riding his horse right into the king's
hall because he doesn't know any better
and this sets up a rivalry between
percival and k which is one of the
subplots of the story so when the red
knight stole the king's cup he actually
spilled or splashed the wine all over
queen guinevere so her honor has been
insulted and none of arthur's knights
are courageous enough to go out and
challenge the red knight
and so percival goes out and he sort of
accidentally kills the red knight with
his javelin um but he's unable to remove
his armor
because he doesn't understand how any of
it works so again he has to ask somebody
how does this work what is this for how
do we put this on so somebody else comes
along and helps him remove the armor and
put it on himself and this is the
beginning of his chivalric career so the
beginning of percival's career as a
night actually begins with a rupture of
communion around a stolen cup right
and to get the cup back he has to go out
and become a knight
and so all of this is uh not without
some regret he is actually sad about he
doesn't want to get rid of the garments
of skin that his mother gave him who
actually puts his armor on over them
rather than discarding them
this is another move up the ontological
ladder and this is accompanied by once
again the crossing of a river
and the meeting of a new mentor so you
could say at this point he's gone as far
as his mother's knowledge can can take
him right he's followed her instructions
very imperfectly but he somehow kind of
stumbled himself a little higher up the
mountain
it crosses this next river
and in this case
it's the the new mentor is a guy by the
name of sir gornamont who is also
sometimes in the poem he's just called
the worthy man
the worthy man teaches percival the ways
of chivalry he teaches him how to write
how to fight how to use his weapons once
again with every weapon the question of
how does this serve or who does this
serve comes up for each of the weapons
he also gives him a new set of
instructions by which he is to live
and once again he's given new clothes uh
which finally uh and he finally gives up
the garments of skin that his mother
gave him which he'd still been wearing
under the armor and he's clothed in new
uh in new garments so he's also given a
set of instructions some of these are
overlaps of the instructions his mother
gave him before but there's some new
ones so he's told now he has to always
show mercy to opponents who surrender
he's told how to behave to maidens which
is just a repeat of the instructions his
mother gave him he's told to go to
church and pray also a repeat but the
fourth thing that he's told and this is
really critical for the story
is that he's supposed to be
taciturn
if he finds himself because this whole
time he's just been asking what's this
what's this what's this it's like my my
four-year-old son you know who just like
we're out driving around doing errands
yesterday and he wants to know why is
that car different from this car what
are the speed bumps in the road for like
he just has all these questions about
all these different things right which
is really fun for me uh because you know
i get to be all knowing for just like a
brief moment you know
um
but he's told if you keep asking all
these questions people will think you're
a peasant people will think you're a
child
you need to keep your mouth closed and
just ask a servant later don't
don't keep asking all these questions
you're embarrassing yourself etc so at
this point we see percival beginning to
mature he makes uh fewer silly mistakes
and seems to know how to behave himself
um he's been initiated into the
chivalric world he's not just a
pretender or an aspirant to it he has in
other words undergone a baptism of sorts
passing out of the north x into the nave
as he's clothed in new garments and now
ready and willing to face the challenges
of this new level of reality and kind of
an adult mature way
and it's interesting
or he's asked to stop asking questions
because you could understand it like his
position in the wild his position at the
at the bottom is basically a question
like who am i what is this you know what
what's the per what are all these things
he's he's almost like inhabiting a kind
of feminine space where he's asking
questions and so he gets initiated up
and then at some point they're saying
okay so now you have to stop being that
lower part you kind of have to engage at
a higher level but i can already see how
that it's interesting that he would
the fact that he would
not be able to recover that at the end
is what would do him in or something
you're getting you're getting ahead but
yes you're you're exactly right that's
that's exactly the right intuition right
so first of all has some adventures most
importantly he meets uh uh blanche
flewer who is sir gorman's daughter the
worthy man's daughter he saves her he
falls in love with her
and in the middle of all this he's
saving the town that she's in from siege
and in the middle of all of this there's
one of what to me is actually one of the
most interesting and kind of evocative
episodes in the poem and i just want to
put this out there to artists i've
actually written a poem about this
particular scene because uh and and its
importance to the rest of the story
because i just find it
incredibly evocative
if you are an artist a painter
maybe an icon carver
and and you'd you'd like to to like help
me with an illustration of this maybe
let's talk about that because this is
i've never seen an illustration of the
scene but it's so
well let me just let me unpack you've
been inspiring me to make a lot of i
know i know i know but you gotta do this
well maybe another one you gotta do this
one so what happens is that he comes to
this
this city which is under siege
and he delivers it but while he's there
he sees a um a minster right like a
monastery church
and he says oh i've been is the first
time he's come across a church but he
says
i've been told i should always go into
one and pray
right and so he goes in
because the town is under siege there
are no monks
who are
um
there are no monks in the sanctuary
and he goes in
and nothing is in good repair we're told
that the walls are cracked and bare
that the towers are ruthless
that the buildings are naked to the
elements day and night
so you have this image
of percival
walking into he's never been to a church
before he's told he's supposed to come
here and worship god
and he walks in and there's no one there
to meet him and the church is desolate
the walls are cracked everything's
crumbling around him
and uh so he's just sort of sad and
confused and he leaves
um this is going to be important later
on in the story but to me it's just one
of the most
i mean if you wanted to sort of explain
uh i know
i know there's a famous classicist who
once said something like
modern people are
barbarians living in the ruins of an
advanced civilization you know
um and to a certain extent like
you know that that image of of like
showing up to a church
and saying you know i'm supposed to be
here to worship god and to do a certain
thing and and here i am i mean you and
bishop aaron were getting into this in a
lot of your recent conversation right
about trying to recover cosmic
christianity and there i i just i have
to tell you this is nothing against
bishop baron who is doing great work and
god bless him
there were many times i wanted to jump
in and say something like um i do you
ever feel that way like when you listen
to other people's yes that way all the
time like man can i could i just can i
just push on that a little bit or say
something here but
um but that was a great conversation and
the uh
the what is it that you wanted to say
richard oh man i'm trying to remember
now i'd have to go i'd have to go back
and listen to there's just a couple of
little there were a couple of little
things
where i was like i was like
um it wasn't so much like disagreeing
with him but i i just wanted to i just
wanted to like like add a little
something i mean that's how you know it
was a good conversation like i felt it
was engaging i felt like i was there and
i wanted to be like oh but but but
um
all right so you're saying but you're
saying that this experience of going
into the church and finding it in
disrespect finding something different
yeah and there's no one there to show
you the way there's no one there because
all those people are
honestly it's not their fault right in
in the case of this you know all the
mugs and the nuns there's actually two
churches he goes into because there's a
monastery and a nunnery in the same city
so it goes into the minister for each of
them and finds them both in the state
right and so all the monks and the nuns
they're they're gone because they are
we're told that they are frightened and
wary so these people are basically just
trying to like survive the city's under
siege
and so they've they've totally left the
maintenance of the house of god to kind
of look after themselves and and you
know try to hold whatever semblance of
life they can together right and i don't
know i just
makes you think of a certain moment uh
yeah
in in our like uh say this moment right
now and i think i mean it's funny
because you're right even sometimes
you know you even people who go in who
who are interested in in orthodoxy you
know sometimes that's that's even their
experience right yeah
they feel like okay
this is not what i was told it was going
to be like 100
well and i i want to say like
for those of us who have had this
experience at some point in our lives
right of of like entering the house of
god and finding it kind of vacant and
empty and crumbling and being like
what's the big deal
why is this really important right
it's not totally the fault of the people
who are there like maybe maybe you could
you could you could say well i wish
every one of these people had had the
martyrs courage to kind of push on
through but even even the stuff that you
and bishop were talking about this is
part of what i wanted to say
is that like the the the kind of the the
denuding of a lot of the beauty of the
catholic tradition right
a lot of those people were were
uh who were pushing that stuff i mean
there definitely was probably some
malice on the part of some people but i
think a lot of people who who went along
with it like the rank and file the just
the normal prisoners the people on the
ground they really thought this was
going to save them yeah right they
really thought this is going to help
them right and so they were they were
already in kind of a
like modernity was was already so ugly
and so strong and so imposing and and
it's really easy to feel like we're just
under siege all the time
and when you're in that mode when you're
thinking in that way
you can let the really beautiful things
go
and and that's that anyway so i i just i
define this particular moment which i've
never heard anybody really talk about or
illustrate uh but i find this particular
moment in the story really really vivid
so all right so uh to push on a little
bit
this is also the first time that he goes
into a church yeah first time he doesn't
go to church yeah i mean it makes sense
too that as he's coming from below
he would kind of encounter the
brokenness and the the fragmented part
of what he moving into right yeah
um
you could you could imagine somebody who
like as as you're coming up from below
and you get into the orthodox church
and you're like oh i'm here now or the
roman catholic church or something
you're like oh i'm here now and things
are so beautiful and then you realize
that actually there's also brokenness
and scandal and there are there are bad
bishops and there are
there are you know acrimonious parish
council meetings
right all you know and and just like
lots of people on the internet who all
have an opinion about how you should be
you know living your life even though
they're not your spiritual father like
you know like you have all these
different things
and uh
and the danger is to do what percival
did which is he gets there and he's like
and he walks out yeah what is this yeah
like what is this what's happening right
so at the end of all of this um before
he marries blanche fleur
uh he decides he needs to return to his
mother
and we get a little detail here uh when
he had when he'd been leaving and
crossing over the river he looked back
over the bridge and he saw his mother
pass out but he just kept going anyway
and so suddenly that recollection kind
of stings him a little bit he's like i
should go see if mom is okay you know
um and so he he goes back to
so he leaves the town that he had saved
and by the way we're told
that he leaves in a procession like unto
the day of ascension
which
um and in intends to bring his mother
back so that she can take the veil he
wants to bring her back to this town
he's in so she can become a nun and he
can be here with his girl and they can
all kind of live together
um and and that i
people watching your channel probably
know this but that's not a bad thing in
the middle ages when you're like i would
like my mom to become a nun
he's he's not saying he's not saying i
want to like put her away so she's not
in my way anymore like this is this is a
good thing like it's a you know
especially if you're like a noble lady
and then you become a nun you you're
usually in charge of the monastery so
it's like in other words he wants his
mom to be looked after and comfortable
and to live this life of beauty and rest
now that he's delivered the city from
from siege
but we're told that uh this is like the
feast
of ascension uh which i think just
brings back to mind that that icon that
the the fresco of the virgin of the
pyrenees right with the
the mother at the center
right in this in this image of ascension
that we talked about last time and there
seems to be echoes of that here and of
course there are a lot of scholars who
think that
um
that's one of the main origins uh for
kretion when he's writing his romance so
you know just a nice nice image there
but percival can't go home again or at
least he can't go home again easily not
the same way that he he left
so he
comes to a third river
and of course the thing is that his
house is on the his home is on the other
side of the third river so it's not
totally clear is the third river a
different river or is it the first one
again right
this is the third river the third
liminal moment in the story
but this time percival can't see a way
to cross
so he meets a man fishing in the river
there's no bridge but he meets a man
fishing the river who tells him go up
the road where he's going to find
lodging and a way across the river
this turns out to be the castle of the
fisher king
and this is where the real adventure of
the grail begins
so the fisher king sits on a bed in the
middle of his castle
he has some kind of a wound in his loins
as a result of which he cannot get up
from his bed
which is exactly the case for percival's
father and in fact we find out at the
end of percival's story that the fisher
king is his mother's brother so he's
percival's uncle and the middle ages to
be your
to be a maternal uncle
is
as close or in some cases actually
closer than being a father
because because if somebody is your
sister's son he can't legally inherit
anything that you have
so he's got no reason to kill you to
take your stuff and he's got no reason
to
and so what what it means is like
there's the there's usually a very
strong bond of love because it's like a
strong bond of loyalty without threat of
usurpation you could say yes
so that's who the fisher king is but
principal doesn't know that yet
um and of course the fisher king is the
same wound as percival's father so it's
like a deliberate kind of recapitulation
so while he's in the fisher king's
castle he sees
a strange procession they're sitting at
the table they're eating and
the door opens and then comes first a
squire
bearing a lance
the tip of which is not merely bloody
but actually bleeding
right because of course
when you stab jesus jesus wounds the
lance right
and so so the the the tip of the spear
is not merely bloodied but it's bleeding
and percival wants to ask what's the
purpose of the lamps
um
he wants to ask the question that he had
asked the knights when he first met them
which is
how does it serve what's it serving
who's it serving
and this is what percival does when he
encounters something new beyond the
knowledge that he has from his previous
identity something beyond the tier of
the ontological ladder which he's used
to inhabiting he wants to ask what's it
for how does it work and then just as
he's about to ask he thinks back to the
advice that the worthy man gave him
which is don't ask too many questions
people will think you're a peasant
people will think you're a child so he
doesn't ask
and the procession continues
and there are two more young men come
out bearing tapers and candelabra
a total of 10 candles and they're
followed by a virgin a young maiden who
bears in her hands a grail which is a
wide shallow covered dish we're told
large enough to serve a pike or a
lamprey in other words it's a very large
dish intended for serving fish
which is an obvious eucharistic symbol
as anyone in the middle ages would have
known yeah
percival is unaware of its contents
though because it's covered but the most
striking thing about the grail is that
it shines brightly with its own light
just like the grail that the virgin
holds in the image of the pyrenees
shines brightly with its own light so
brightly that it far out shines the
large candelabra which preceded it and
once again percival is just dying to
know what is all of this about the grail
is clearly special it's holy it's
valuable but there's no clear indication
as to why the procession is happening or
why it's happening now so the question
he wants to ask is how does this serve
who is it serving
principal wants to know
but again he thinks back to the
worthy man's advice
and he doesn't ask
and once again as the table before him
being filled with these unimaginable
delicacies
the grail passes before him again the
lance the whole procession and once
again he wants to ask the question
who's it served once again he keeps his
mouth shut and by the way he's also not
observed any of the other pieces of
advice he was given he doesn't ask the
name of the man who shows him
hospitality if he did he'd find out it
was his uncle
um he uh if he'd asked that a great deal
of trouble would have been saved uh he
so he decides to wait until the next
morning and ask at the servants
but when he awakens the next morning the
castle is totally empty
and the chance to ask the question has
been lost yeah
so the very next person that he meets is
the maiden whose ring he stole back at
the beginning of the story
and uh whose life he unintentionally
ruined
she tells him the story of the fisher
king
that he was a king a noble wounded by
battle in battle biolance which pierced
him through both of his sighs thighs
which is same story he was told about
his father she excitedly questions
percival because she assumes that he is
asked the question uh who
how searched the grail whom does it
serve and when she finds out that he is
not asked she becomes distraught she
mocks percival and it is this moment
is when percival's true name is revealed
which he has not known up to this point
of course his mother once told him by a
name you will know a man
and now for the first time percival
comes to real self knowledge but it's a
deeply painful self-knowledge
so if we want to follow our liturgical
reading of the story we see this third
river which may or may not be the first
river kind of symbolizes the third and
the final barrier to principles ascent
up the mountain it's the veil drawn over
the holy of holies it's the rude cree
root screen the iconistas which seems to
bar the way to the mysteries
and given the dependency of grail
legends uh like i said on on the
the divine liturgy the rituals of the
christian east
i don't think it's surprising here that
the grail procession as many many
scholars have noted is basically
identical to the great entrance which is
when the patents and the chalice are
brought out
accompanied by tapers and incense and if
there are enough clergy serving one of
them will also carry a knife
yeah which we call the spear or the
lance which is used to divide the body
of christ
um
yeah which is something i think a lot of
people don't necessarily know that right
yeah yeah yeah actual utensil that is
used to cut the
it's actually used in the liturgy to
pierce the right the bread is is
definitely related to the land itself
it's related to lance it's it's the
spear right so
you have silence and speech and laughter
all playing a crucial role in this tale
in a lot of ways i i didn't have time to
get into um as they do in most arthurian
stories actually
um
you you need a you know to link back to
your merlin story that you had like two
years ago because i think it's time that
people got that back in their
consciousness now now that we've seen a
lot of things happen over the last two
years it would be good to remind people
of that story
um
so here's the thing there's a time to
keep silent before a mystery
but this is not the kind of silence
which percival has been enjoying to
practice by the worthy man his silence
might be characterized by the old adage
often repeated to me by my father
because i'm a talkative person right
that light is faster than sound that's
why everybody looks smart until they
open their mouth
um
uh so this is the silence of somebody
who's been embarrassed before somebody
who's looked foolish looked childish
before and has spent the rest of their
life from that moment on trying to prove
that they should be taken seriously
uh for some you know there's lots of
examples of this happening in the poem
uh that people people can go and read
for themselves
but the source
of
percival's child niches his childhood
childishness and his naivete is his lack
of a father right somebody who could
have taught him the use of arms and most
importantly would have given him his
true name conferring identity upon him
and in the castle of the fisher king
percival is really close to healing this
wound
um all he has to do is to ask the right
question
yeah but the question is basically what
is it and what's its reason it's like
it's basically the ontological question
yeah right right which is the
fundamental question that percival
asked when he was down here
yeah that's what makes you go up the
ontological hierarchy in the first place
like right you're you're about you're
amongst a bunch of stuff
and then you ask you kind of see this
stuff coming together and then you ask
oh what is it what is it for and once
you do that then you can jump up
you know
a level right that's how you that's
actually you know even in the most
immediate way
that's how we move from levels from
levels of reality
you know to use the the basic example
that everybody mocks you for using all
the time now it's like this it's the
same question with like you have a bunch
of parts of something like parts of a
chair and then you have to ask like what
is this
when you see them coming together what
is it for and once you know that it's
for sitting on then you've you've jumped
up a level like you've actually
actually
gone up a level in in an ontological
hierarchy of course it's not the same as
all the way up to the grail but you can
understand this as an image of how
reality works and how things
how things come together and how they
kind of move up you know into into into
reality and that in a way you can see
that when you go up you have to
you kind of have to assume the level
that you are and you have to stop asking
the question at first only when you
reach the next level that you have to
start asking questions again but if you
ask questions when you're
or think about it like if you master
something
you have to master it and you have to
live it if you if you keep asking
questions you're not
you're not you're not mastering it but
once you read when you reach the next
level then you have to be willing or
capable of asking
questions again
but in this story it seems like it's
like a cycle where he seems to like it
as if he comes back home
but now his home
is like a higher version of his home you
could say
but he's just not totally able to
to get there me like you said maybe
because he lacks a father he doesn't
have that identity confirmed upon him
he's not capable of asking the right
question to kind of connect with his
because it's it's clear that his uncle
his father
that's it's related it's trying to get
you to see that
there's something
pretty much the same thing is going on
right and the mystery that he saw at the
beginning with the different objects
that he asked about is the same mystery
now he's seeing
but at a higher level
and now he can't he can't pierce it so
why do you say that it's a it's a
success so
if he'd ask this question he's told
the fisher king would have been healed
instead ruined comes upon his family his
mother has died the young man in whose
life he's ruined turns out to be his
cousin the land suffers as a result
so in divine liturgy
um
the very last thing that we say before
communion begins to the to the to the
laity right is the holy things are for
the holy yeah it's a challenge it's a
warning it's a statement
about who these mysteries are for
they are for those who put on christ we
say one is holy one is lord jesus christ
right
um who are these four these are four
little children
they're for people who put on christ
they're for those who come to be fed and
not just to be fed but we don't
in our church we don't pick up we don't
pick up the elements and feed ourselves
we are fed with a spoon right i have i
have uh four children i've got another
kid on the way in january right like i
fed lots and lots of kids with spoons
right it's it's messy sometimes it's um
but it's necessary right
and so
to receive communion is
is self-knowledge it's the it's the
ultimate it's like the only real
self-knowledge right it's a it's to find
yourself in christ
it heals the wound of our father adam
and it bestows upon us a name that no
man knows that's what saint john says
excommunication though is also a kind of
self-knowledge
right it's anyone who has experienced
the pain of ever being denied communion
or or either as a catechumen you know
catechumens depart right chase you out
of the church
or or or a penitent
knows this really well
so at this first time and here's the
thing people always miss is that he gets
a second chance okay but at this first
time percival fails to achieve the grail
he fails to enter into the healing of
communion because he can't come to it as
that child yeah he can't yeah he can't
make himself small again yeah at the
level where he is so that he can
perceive and so
there's a lot that happens at this point
in the story he has some more adventures
uh which sort of culminate in him
writing the wrong to his cousin right so
he sort of solves all of that problem
and the narrative passes on to some of
arthur's knights in particular gawain
i'm not even going to talk about that
stuff in the story today when we meet
percival again
when we meet first of all again we find
him a lost and broken man
he spent
the last five years wandering in the
waist
looking for the lance and for the grail
he's looking for healing and communion
and he can't find his way
he has forgotten everything
including god he's forgotten god he's
forgotten the laws of chivalry he's even
forgotten his own name
and when next we meet him percival has
spent these last five years pursuing one
adventure after another never stopping
at a chapel to pray we're told never
paying attention to the favor or the
needs of ladies we're told uh in in
short
pursuing d's of arms but never attending
to the things that either his mother or
the worthy man had instructed him to do
and this culminates one day he's riding
along
and he sees
three unarmed knights
along with some ladies walking through
the woods
and they stop him and they say sir don't
you know it's unlawful to wear arms on
this day
and he says what's today what's special
about today and they said this is good
friday this is the day on which our lord
jesus died you're not supposed to go
armed today he said well i don't know
who jesus is and i don't know what good
friday is
and so they tell him
they tell him
well go back through the woods that
direction
we've tied knots on the ends of
branches
to
show you the way
and you'll find a hermitage
and go to that hermitage and ask the
hermit and he will tell you
what to do
so percival follows these instructions
he follows the knots on the branches
until he comes to the hermitage
and he meets the hermit
and he starts telling the hermit his
whole story and asking what's this all
about and what the hermit does is he
begins by catechizing percival
he catechizes him by telling him and we
get the whole thing he explains the
entire creed to percival
which had been taught to first of all
but he'd never been taught what it meant
so he categorized his percival and then
he tells first of all who he is he tells
him his name
he tells him
who his father was and he reveals the
fact that he is also
percival's uncle
with the hermit the hermit
is a fisher king
he's
i'll i'll i'll i'll be a little
apathetic here and say what the poem
says which is
the fisher king is percival's uncle
and the hermit
is percival's uncle
are they the same person
all right
yeah
so
hold on i was trying to pull up i was
trying to pull up this passage because
uh it's really really beautiful
the worthy man
uh which by the way the the permit is
also called the worthy man so he's like
every mentor right yeah all right join
together yeah
um
misfortune has followed you of a sin for
which you are ignorant and he finds out
the reason that he failed to ask the
question
was because he left his mother when she
died
um and so he talks about all this
and he says here's what he says here's
what he says okay
foolish were you not to learn who was
served from the bowl the man who is
served from it was my brother so
he's not the fisher king but he's kind
of the fisher king
my sister who was
and his was your mother as for that rich
fisher king he is i believe
um
the son of the king who is himself
served from the bowl so talking about
the bowl what's in the bowl he asked
what's in the bowl and he's told
what is in the bowl is not
a salmon or a pike or a lamprey but
rather a single sacred wafer
carried to him in the bowl
we know he sustains and nourishes his
life
such a holy object is in the bowl and so
pure in spirit is he himself that this
life requires no in this life he
requires no further nourishment than the
host that comes from the bowl
so
there's uh
all kinds of stuff going on here but at
the end of it all he catechizes first of
all
and at the end of catechism he says now
that he's told him who he is
and he's told him
why bad things happened to him and he's
told him what the grail was and what his
purpose was
gets the end of the poem and here's what
we're told
he says stay with me for the next three
days and eat what i eat
well you have to read between the lines
here it's good friday yeah three days
from now is easter
eat what the hermit eats in other words
fast with me
mm-hmm so
percival basically saying you will get
what you will get come from the grave
yeah so first of all
isaac is catechized he fasts
and we're told
that on easter day
thus percival came to know that god was
crucified and died on for on the friday
and on easter
percival received communion
with a pure heart
and then we're told here the tale says
no more of percival
okay you've totally convinced me that
person that's the end of his story
so he finds the grail but how does he
find the grail he has to come to it
broken
he has to come to it like just totally
emptied of who he is
and to come again as a little child and
to sort of say who am i why am i here
what is this thing
right and then he's catechized and then
he fasts and we're actually told he puts
on the hair shirt that the hermit is
wearing
you know again it's a change of garment
a change of identity well he puts back
the hair shirt from the beginning but
now it's a penitential exactly accent
it's the opposite of the hair shirt
received from adam and eve in a way so
isn't that interesting that the garment
of skin become like at the at the
beginning it just sort of becomes this
identity of death but then later when
you put it you can you can take that
death on yourself and so by remembering
your death
it becomes transformed into life
that's amazing i mean it's amazing also
it's like he discovers that the grail is
not the one in a way is not the one cup
it's not the cup that he saw in the in
the castle basically yeah in this poem
it's not um in in this poem the grail is
not the the idea of the cup of the last
supper that comes from bravo deborah
which is which is later
um and that's definitely the most
successful version but in this it's it's
a it's a dish that holds
the eucharistic host
and so when we're told that and then
literally a page later we're told
on easter personal receive communion
with a pure heart and here the tale says
no more percival
like you have to look at that and say
right he discovered his identity he's
discovered who he is and this this idea
i mean one of the things you have to
always keep in mind when you're reading
medieval literature is that man is a
microcosm
so
by healing percival
all these other people and things that
he's interacted with which in the story
are basically sort of externalizations
of of
his
his lack of identity right and and his
his attempt to sort of climb the
ontological ladder all that stuff is
actually fulfilled and healed
right and that's why that's why the
mentor is is
like
she feeds it dementor feeds and clothes
him so it's the mentor you know that
hurt the hermit feeds him clothes and
becomes his mother he comes he's
referred to as the worthy man
right so he becomes he becomes you know
sir uh the worthy man he uh but he's
also the brother of the fisher king so
he becomes you know so he's like every
every sort of culmination of all the
thresholds right are sort of gathered up
in him
so
what's super interesting like what
really fascinates me about what you're
saying is also
if if what you're saying is is is real
like if you're framing it properly it
also shows the manner in which the the
the like the esoteris like the kind of
uh theosophist and the occultist
they were always looking for another
mystery like they they had the sense in
which the the christian mystery
was not enough and they were looking for
these other mysteries and a lot of the
esoteric stuff that went around the
grail was this idea that there is this
other initiation there's this other
mystery that we can can access that is
that is hard and that it's hidden but
you can see that in at least in percival
at least in this version
it leads up to communion as being the
highest mystery as being that which
culminates his whole life into this
moment where because it also there is a
sense in which while he's going around
he doesn't know who christ is but his
mom says his mother says to go into a
church but he he hasn't been properly
catechized he doesn't understand the
mystery of christ and so he can it kind
of all culminates into this to this last
moment
and uh we're told i mean lots of
beautiful little details here at the end
right um
when percival first comes to the starts
walking down the path and i would love
to know if you have a take
on the the knotted tree branches that
line the path yes it's mentioned
multiple times and i still don't totally
understand like what's the significance
of that
well you can understand it you can
understand it the way you understand a
prayer role
right so you you have to understand like
uh
that's so obvious once you say it i'm
like oh gosh it's a well a prayer rope a
rosary like it's uh yeah so prayer ropes
and rosies are like little worlds that
connect that are connected together
right so it's like you but also like a
progression right you you progress up a
hierarchy and then you have higher
steps and you keep moving
uh yeah and so what what happens as he
moves along we're told that as he walks
past the knots
he felt his very heart sighing because
he knew that he'd sinned against god and
he was sorry and in tears he made his
way towards the forest
and when he reached the hermitage he
dismounted and disarmed
so uh disarmed means he took all of his
armor off yeah right
ties his horse to a tree and he enters
the herm's dwelling and it says in that
small chapel
he found the hermit and a priest and a
young cleric this is the truth who were
beginning the service the sweetest and
most beautiful that may be said in holy
church so he shows up at the beginning
of mass right yeah it shows up thinking
the beginning of mass which is what
that's the grail procession
right so he shows up at the chapel
and it's happening again
and this time
he falls to his knees
and the hermit sees him weeping
and comes over to him and he he
he says and principle wants to receive
communion
and and
and the the hermit tells him you have to
make your confession first before you
receive communion right and so that's
what that's what initiates the
conversation between them the exchange
principles reclaiming of identity it's
through this act of confession which
becomes a repetition of his catechesis
and his repentance culminates in you
know fasting praying receiving communion
so it's i mean there's all these just
really beautiful details in here and
there's a bunch of stuff in the story
that i haven't even talked about
there's a lot of things i still haven't
really understood though they seem to be
symbolically significant like there's an
intuition that there's something there
but yeah
yeah but also
some of it is just um some of it is just
like every detail in this poem
is significant and
to try and summarize it and explain like
my overarching thesis
about it is very difficult
if you keep getting hung up on all the
granular levels like
one of the things that comes up over and
over again in this
in this uh poem is the symbolism of the
cloak people have cloaks that they put
on that they take off that they give to
other people at certain times right um
which is really interesting so
um but it certainly had to do with the
the garmented skin and then the
different clothing that he has at
different levels and the armor
also it probably is all related you'd
have to look at what in what condition
in what moment do they remove the cloak
and and what is it what does it imply
yeah yeah so there's there's just a lot
of stuff a lot of stuff in this story um
and of course there's a whole gawain
portion of this so what's interesting is
that gawain in this poem and that's the
part of the poem that's not finished
gawain in this poem isn't looking for
the grail he's specifically looking for
the lamps
so if i had to sort of like fanfic this
up a little bit and i feel like i'm i'm
justified in doing so because everyone
in the middle ages did
i would not have great uh
i would not have gawain continue
searching for the grail
i would have him find the lance so you'd
have like sort of the person who finds
the grail going finds the lance and
that's how i would end the that's how i
would end the romance that makes sense
like you're ready but it makes sense
especially if the idea that personal
does indeed find the grayer right so the
gawain would find something equivalent
to the lands but let's say in terms of
maybe
something about the crucifixion or
something in that right yeah
so that might be a fun that might be a
fun project to take up one of these days
is to try to do my up do my own they're
called the continuations i could do
definitive continuation right so uh yeah
all that to say whether or not you think
percival found the grail he found the
grail he didn't even because he received
communion there's no doubt exactly
so all right so richard roland
revolutionizing but not just
revolutionizing but just proving to all
the modern scholars that you know
cassandra what he was doing
and uh yeah you know that
for sure percival found the grail um
and so so yeah so thanks we will
continue on we there's no
there's no stopping this conversation so
is there something you wanted to tell us
tell everybody before we uh we we let
them go um i don't know when this will
drop but we're currently in uh the
advent season or the nativity fast if
you're uh orthodox christian i would
just tell everyone um
keep your eyes open and your ears open
right now
um there's the there's a this is i like
to say crazy things on other people's
podcasts because then like if they
choose not to edit it out that's their
fault um so there's this there's this
there's this tradition
like a sort of like a folk superstition
that on christmas eve
you know and this is also true this
whole idea of like halloween and other
like the night before like good friday
as well like the night before a really
holy day right is a day when like the
barriers between worlds are like really
thin and stuff can slip through
and um
bad things can happen but also good
things could happen
and um what i would just say is be uh be
really attentive during the season and
pay attention
because
things are going to um and i think
especially if you're a western person i
think christmas
i mean i think we all know christmas is
bigger than easter in the west it just
is right whether or not that should be
the case um but and
in a certain way i think like there's a
particular western genius to the way
that we celebrate christmas like some of
those old christmas carols and i've been
posting a bunch of them on facebook like
those things are a symbolic gold mine
yeah and mine and i don't think you can
really beat them
yeah christmas tree is so awesome you
can't yeah yeah not a lot of stuff yeah
yeah no we have a there's a particular
western genius for celebrating christmas
and what i would say is just be just be
really attentive to the things that are
happening the patterns that are
manifesting this season um and of course
at the end of it all look for christ
so
all right thanks richard and so uh yeah
i think that's true we probably will
drop this just before christmas so i
wish you i wish all of you merry
christmas as well and we'll see you in
the new year
this episode is part of a series of
discussions i've had with richard roland
on universal history you can find a list
of all these episodes on my youtube
channel where you can find them also in
my podcast stream from the symbolic
world on your different podcast
platforms make sure to check out
richard's second podcast which he hosts
in collaboration with father andrew
damick called amman sewell which looks
at the relationship between tolkien and
orthodoxy this podcast has also inspired
me some ideas for creating some images
whether it be the king under the
mountain whether it be the grail or
beautiful ethiopian traditions i've
created some products which you can find
on my store the symbolicworld.store
and there will probably be more of those
to come very soon so stay tuned this
conversation is ongoing and there is
still very much to explore in the
universal history